I have been in the development world for
far too long not to believe that an
individual can have an enormous impact
and in coming to women's world banking
I'd say the greatest privilege is that I
meet literally daily women who are
clients who are leaders of our
institutions founders of our
organizations whose lives if left to
their own devices would have gone in a
very very different path but because of
their their commitment their dedication
they're they're seeing or wrong and not
allowing it to to stand have made an
enormous impact I am a great believer
and the individuals impact and the
individuals impact on the system to
change that system you know there's
always an opportunity to give money if
that's an if that's an option but giving
money is just got sufficient you've got
to really make sure that the people that
you're giving your money to are keeping
their eyes on the things that really
matter to you and if you are passionate
about women's empowerment making sure
that the organization that you're
supporting is paying particular
attention to the things that might stand
in women's way if there were a silver
bullet what would what would it be what
would you want to track what is the
intervention that does or doesn't make a
difference what we found is if you have
explicitly in your mission statement
that you want to serve low-income women
it's it's really quite remarkable the
number of indicators that you hit right
on the money as they pertain to women
you know it's the old what gets measured
gets done but that's every bit as true
with social mission as it is you know on
the you know entirely commercial side
and so even in our network we have 39
institutions in our network 27 countries
all of them don't have that explicit
commitment to women everyone either
wanted to alleviate poverty or there
were there were very lofty missions but
it was the one
who specifically communicated we're
about serving women that then when they
measured themselves against it really
were you know philanthropy is wonderful
and we in the United States are the most
generous people in the world but being
smart about what your money is actually
out there doing I think is there is a
real responsibility of the
philanthropist